are we live
i think
we are
hello
first ever youtube live stream by the
way well
first one in a couple years so bear with
me as i
start this for the first time
first time in two years
so
it's gonna be a learning curve here on
youtube but we will give it a shot
let's see let me make sure i push this
out
real quick dude i think the chat will
work i hope
i think
uh let's see edit
i mean if i just go
here
nice okay
that looks kind of cool
let's do
this don't need that
do a little bit of that
a little bop
and
i can pin chat oh yeah i can pin chat
okay cool
cool man
let's go to discord hit it with a little
bit of that
[Music]
um
[Music]
live on youtube
i hope
it's hard to tell if anything's working
but we'll we'll give it a shot we'll
we'll get it going here
told y'all goats are annoying dude goats
do be kind of strong
let's go here let's start up the game
baby let's get it
i hope everyone's having a great day
good morning good afternoon good evening
whatever wherever the hell you're from
hope you're having a good day
i think we should
oh give it a shot man
it's because we're not the same
okay
game seems to be working
that's good
okay
i haven't been on camera
in a while
so bear with me here
[Music]
see it says go live right there
does that mean i'm not live
am i live i hope so let's find out
let's go to my phone and figure that one
out
boom
yep we're live i think we're good okay
let's get it going so we are on
my fourth playthrough this is new game
plus four
i've beaten the game one other time on
one other character
[Music]
but i love roaming around on
my my main boy my main character what
have i been using
i was using
blade sword
which is actually really fun to use i
was using
the darkmoon greatsword for a while
and it's fun i like it i might want to
put some uh
some smithing stones in the executioner
sword
uh i'll think about that later because
that that could be really fun the royal
greatsword this is what i've been
using looks so cool dude
i wonder what these runes on the side
mean
i mean obviously we can't read runes
but uh
kind of cool if we could
but i was exploring the shaded castle
whoops
which has a lot of cool connections to
melania actually
but
um
i'm going to save that for a video later
today
hey josh how are you
where can we go now which where should
we go what should we do
we explored that area pretty pretty good
um
thank you nikki and austin as well
josh goes oh [ __ ]
oh man what
there's so much to do
that i don't even know where to go i
haven't explored caled at all or we
could just do all of uh limb grave
honestly
let's just go to limb grave and start
there
because i've just been kind of bee
lining up the left side
what's up goshi how you doing today
thanks for coming by the live stream
first ever youtube live stream
it's gonna be a learning curve but we'll
get it
my congratulations
now
visit the round table hold does
everything sound good
i hope with the two fingers
i already did that
i forget what i have to do to trigger
him to go somewhere else
because i know he goes to some church
out in the like uh
learning lakes
i just don't know where
anyway
oh glenn god she gotcha gotcha i mean
that doesn't matter
but
you're good
youtube youtube's different man
what do you think we're getting the
first dlc of elden ring
i have no idea
they're usually pretty quick
with it have i fought the dragon i don't
think i have they're usually pretty
quick
probably uh
um
within
within the year i'd say
definitely within the year
oh my god that hurt
whoops
i can't see
one thing i don't like about these
dragon fights man i can't see
but i have no idea yashi
hopefully sooner rather than later
i freaking love it
oh are you gonna fly
let's do the weapon art on this
that might have been a mistake
it's too slow
i didn't even know dragons could punch
head
there we go
nice
that's pretty easy
not
too shabby
i have not messed around with the dragon
communions like at
thank you for putting me on this game it
is
it was a marvelous adventure and a great
entry into the from software game
adventures
right
the i hope that's what most people get
out of this glenn is um
they go back and play the other games
that they never gave it never gave a
chance to
all of the from software games are good
every single one
i'd rate it i elden ring is at the top
for me
bloodborne's close
if you haven't played bloodborne
you should
saqiro
after that
dark souls 3 was my entry into the
franchise
dark souls 1 is fantastic it's showing
its age now a bit
but dark souls 1 is is fantastic
in its own way
and then um
dark souls 2 is dark souls 2. i don't i
don't like it
um but i did like certain aspects of it
i think you would give it a try maybe
you'd like it more than i would you know
who knows
but i'm really happy you enjoyed it
glenn i'm very happy
that didn't hit
let me try that again
i may not need you sir
stab
there we go wow you did so much
jesus
calm down my man it's like apparently
the best bleed dagger in the game right
there
i know he's standing over there we could
see what patches once
it's great because it gives the player a
look and what to expect from the other
games to kind of help guide them along
i agree i i will say that um those other
games are way harder than this one in my
opinion i think eldon ring is
not the easiest
but it's the most accessible one i think
a lot of people
won't like
uh i don't i won't say they won't like
it
but they they may notice that it's not
as accessible as this game is
for sure when you play like sakiro it's
like you need when you're playing sakiro
you need to get good
you need to learn the combat or you're
you're done
ain't no shot
you're getting past them you know
nice
so we're gonna go look for patches up in
here what up beep
how we doing beep
get the mongoose beat
yeah hopefully everything looks and
sounds okay this is my first live stream
on youtube
uh in
three years so
let me know
it's a dab emote
nice
whenever i unlock all the stuff i can in
uh on youtube then we'll get some custom
emotes up in here
right now i'm not even monetized on
youtube right now technically i am but i
have to get uh my google adsense
account
it's it's under review and it's it'll be
accepted it'll look fine looks and
sounds good
huge
let's see what patches wants
sekiro's learning curve absolutely is
absolutely is
more live streams i agree
well well well
should we meteorite him
are you gonna come down here dog okay
what let's meet your item
i can't even see him
that was kind of sick
laser beam
wow that is a nice shield you got there
my man
all right chad do we kill him
you know what i'm just gonna kill him
he's dirty man
patches
another character that's in every single
from software game i believe
you get a plus seven spear from him
like for real
i'm doing 241 plus 136.
yeah he pushed me off a cliff too
what a dick
you get a plus seven spear from him
where is it
it's a spear it should be right there
oh
pike partisan iron plus oh i've already
done this i've done this three times
apparently and just noticed this
it doesn't do that much damage
but that's cool that would be a good
starting weapon
because this is like right in the first
starting area
creepy spider patches in bloodborne
lurk it up beep i have no commands we're
figuring it all out today
what class uh are you playing so i'm
playing a mix of a strength build
and a uh
intelligence build
i'm level like
221
this is a hardcore new game plus
character
like i'm so over leveled on this
character it's
it's kind of crazy
work it out beep
yeah glenn to to talk about your
learning curve on skiro it's it's nuts
like it's totally different
but fantastic in its own way
like you can't uh you have to deflect
you have to learn the deflects in uh
sakiro or you're just you're dead
for sure
this weather is terrible
this also an area that i have not really
looked at that much what are on these
are those just leaves
i think so i thought they were like
apples or something
the last boss is so hard
i mean ratagon
and the elden beast
pretty tough fight
i mean a parry god yes sir
let's go over here what's what's under
this cave
oh yeah
i should have went and talked to that
guy
because if if he's here
if you don't already fight the dragon
and he warns you to not fight the dragon
as we just rush in there and fight the
dragon
yeah ratagan and the elden beast
i mean it's a tough fight but it's not
the hardest one
what's going on over here
where are they fighting
so it's the demi humans and golden order
guys i think
i mean they're the ones at war
so that makes sense this weather is nuts
i don't think i've experienced this
weather in this game
oh i'm sure i have but i don't really
notice it
the heck are they doing
hello
ew we all got red eyes
what's going on down here
oh here we go
[Music]
oh here we go
let's bring out the uh hold on
they don't really shoot spells so i
don't need that shield
pretty much kills them all in one hit
nice i love this build though this
intelligent strength build is really fun
i've been having a good time with it oh
[ __ ]
i just took a shower and my hair is
still wet and it's dripping onto my face
okay
anything over here
why were there so many enemies here
with nothing to jump on
very interesting
crab eggs
is there a cave
no
okay
okay
um
[Music]
we're not making that jump
heck no
weird
surprising
a bunch of enemies protecting crab eggs
it's about right
it's about right
okay
see which way am i heading right now
pretty much down to the south
i find that the south
and you guys let me know if you feel the
same way
i find this area of the game down here
to be the most boring
but maybe i just haven't found the best
spots yet
because that's possible
that's where i just was right yeah okay
maybe i haven't found the good spots
down there is the demi-human queen i
believe
i think i can see it
i think a lot of people miss this boss
down here i think you can see its leg
yep
demi-human queen right there
i'm just going to be exploring
finding cool stuff
randomly hitting wildlife as i pass by
them oh they're lurking
those guys would be way more of a factor
if they didn't scream before they like
you know jump me
like the point of an ambush is to come
out of nowhere and use screaming
kind of like
not super smart
get a jump pad here what the heck
oh you're a big boy
and now you're dead
okay
see like i always think are they
protecting a cave
or something
what up kyle
is that d kyle
i hope
damn this game is pretty bro
is that a cave right there
torrent
torrent god dammit
that's a cave
oh how we doing today kyle son of a
[ __ ] torrent all right
that's cave for sure
we can go check that out
oh there's that annoying bridge
um
i do want to explore this area today so
let's get it just looking around
we
i love happened
okay
just checking to see if anything's there
i don't think there is
we got some eggles up here i refuse to
hit an egg
just won't do it
i even get up here
oh
did i mess up
you know what i need to do
dude i wonder can i make that jump all
the way across if i use this no
because this thing launches you straight
up right
do we test
i wonder
yeah that that takes you straight up man
there's no shot
okay let's go this way
oh that doesn't even get me up there
you forget i've played skyrim though
and know how to finagle finagle a
mountain
do we know more about these things yet
because i don't
i don't know nothing
we can fight the forlorn
oh i didn't use uh blade is he here
black
blotty i don't think i've met him yet or
we've already gone that far i think
oh boy don't stagger our boy don't
stagger bro
oh that one hurt though didn't it
daryl
oh no
oh no
uh let me get one heal off buddy
thank you
there it is
that's the weirdest way for us to do
that
but why not
10k runes right there
boom
also what are the evergales
i i actually have not questioned that
a single time
what are these
what are these little wormy boys
because i'm not gonna lie they look like
anal beads
what are they doing
see i would think they were activating
the evergill but they're not
this thing have an eye
ew
i haven't noticed that have you guys
seen that before
it has an eyeball on the end
i did not like that
this one's glowing
weird
see those are the fine details you don't
notice
you know unless you look
yo what up trey
what up hal
are we doing
oh god
oh god
we
no double jump
they have so much on this bridge
i said a reminder and it told me nothing
um you have to
enable notifications
i mean i just started like 20 minutes
ago
so like you go to like where it says
subscribe
now
you know where it says subscribe
and then uh
there's a little bell
you gotta set that
i'm like level 221
i don't really well actually you can
always use a stone sword key
yeah yeah
i'm just gonna go rest over here i don't
like there is no significance to this
bridge at all it's just kind of weird
i did it the little bell fella there you
go
that should work i don't really know how
reminders work
depends on how many subscribers you have
like
yeah yeah yeah
oh we got irina over here did we help
her out
it's like is there more to this bridge
than i'm missing
let's let's inspect
because it seems just kind of like
slapped on here
a little bit
hello
are you gonna make money on youtube ad
revenue
uh and
there's a tip option in the description
there's also um
yup i'm i'm getting my channel looked at
right now to get the join button as well
so in good time
mr kenzie
in good time we will have it all but
right now we're just getting started and
we're just streaming for fun
but uh ad revenue
just watching the stream
makes me [ __ ] money man
then the other cool thing is this live
stream is put on youtube after i'm done
so people can go watch it make money off
ad revenue there it's kind of sick
whereas twitch it's just there for no
reason
i should see what that item is
it's probably some
crossbow
a dagger okay
lame
100 times prefer youtube over twitch so
do i
also uh hopefully the stream looks
really good i'm not even sure
excuse me i'll have to check afterward
but uh
bit rate
compared to twitch is so much higher
so it should look really good
then again i'm not sure
depends on your internet too
i suppose
man
i could stream in 4k
but
that seems
excessive
y'all see nothing about this bridge
this is just a weird bridge
is there like
a little under part over here that i'm
missing
we got a little troll under the bridge
oh all right
reset
reset
let's see
let's talk to irina
it's a quest line i've never finished
is somebody there is this sword not
awesome
[Music]
there is a lot less delay too that is
true
the servants there have rebelled
i
i can't be sure what it is
my eyesight's been weak since birth you
see but i swear i heard frightful
howling what is up with the eyesight
with the npcs in this game like so many
of them are like really have really bad
eyesight it's probably because you have
a blindfold over your face i can't help
this commander
but she pretty much just wants us to
tell her dad to get out of the castle
so we'll get the letter
[Music]
we'll give it to him
only downside might be custom-made
customization of what widgets you can
have on your screen
uh all of that is the same as twitch
actually it's kind of cool
i prefer to not have that much on the
screen
i even debated not even having a camera
but
people seem to like the camera so i will
keep the camera on
let's look around here i i always just
run through this area like as fast as i
can
this area scowy
get that dog before it hits me
saw that coming
why does twitch exist
um
the culture
some people prefer the culture of twitch
to uh
to youtube
uh
i have found
that i don't
[Music]
okay
those dogs didn't even care bro these
guys don't even care dude
okay nice
nice
ripped 200k channel points i earned on
twitch hi fitzy yeah
plus people who subscribed on twitch for
a long time probably like ah rip
it's definitely just time to move on
though it really is twitch has just
never been kind to me
except for that one month
so
i'm happy
i've been much happier since i stopped
doing stuff on twitch
i'll i'll probably moderate a lot of you
guys
um
like who were the regulars on twitch
this depends
because i don't i don't really know
i'm just gonna stream that's
we'll see what happens right now we
don't really need any
so we got one of these carriages which
apparently is a coffin
i didn't know that until recently
because there i don't think i have it on
this map maybe i do
i do
uh
do i
i don't think it's that one
but if you go here after going through
like this entire like ravine system area
you pop out up here and it tells you
that those are um these are all coffins
that they carry those giants
that are just walking by
big giant coffins had no idea
i just thought they were like loot
but
yeah i don't know who their coffins of
but yeah
oh yeah i did not stream regularly at
all
my plan
i'm gonna stick to this as hard as i can
trey
wednesday through sunday
at noon for about three hours
does that sound good
wednesday through sunday i take mondays
and tuesdays off
let's make videos or whatever
nerd
for about three to four hours depending
five days a week
we'll see how it do
but that is the schedule that i'm going
for
he's like youtube will tell me it's like
most of your subscribers are online
between 12 and 4 and i'm like oh
it was even like if you know live
streaming preferred at this time i was
like oh
i was about to hit a year of subbing
i want to look into ludwig's thing
because he got his subs to transfer from
twitch and keep their status like their
month-long status i will have to look at
the ludwig plug-in and see if that's
something we can do too because i would
like to do that i have to get the join
button first which um we should be
getting soon
from what my uh
my youtube
partner
helper guy phillip
uh told me
i'm always on youtube too trey
that was a thing like i never watch
twitch
like very often at all unless it's like
beeper or jen or whoever
i don't watch twitch
you'd be at a year at end of april
it's something i'll look at and see if
we can do i wasn't sure if it was like
just for him or it's like a plug-in
that anybody can get
i'm gonna look back over here real quick
so i want to see what's going on over
here
yeah that's something i could look at
if not it's a new journey
i don't think anything's here
oh yeah and maggie too yup yup yup yup
exactly
yeah twitch's culture is very um
niche
it's like what is this right here is
this a bridge or something that fell
it's like something fell there and it
got wedged
into the side
i don't know though
but i will look into that fitsy because
i was thinking of that
so there's another is that a carriage or
the the funeral thing no that's a
building okay it looks very similar
see what is that right here
what are these gravestones sticking out
of a mountain for
like are there people buried in the
mountain
you can get the turtle shield up there
got our boy over here
i think my character looks [ __ ]
awesome
look at this
i feel like everything matches
nice blue cape
cool uh designs on the armor
you got a new job are you serious for
real
what do you do with the bicycle company
that sounds awesome
you're a spokesperson like legit
that's different from what you were
doing yeah
holy [ __ ]
good for you man how did how did that
come about
one thing i've come to really appreciate
on from software games is the fluidity
of combat
yeah it's [ __ ] uh
the combat like some people call it
janky and i'm like it's not janky it's
just hot it's hard
to get used to the combat in games like
this but they are so good once you
realize that
you know
it's so good
and you control how fluid you are as
well
which i like
oh my god trey i thought you were being
serious
to my head i was like the [ __ ] like
straight like bikes
is really like some engineering going on
here
okay it's hard to tell when you're
joking when your pixel's on screen i'm
just saying man
but i'm gullible as [ __ ]
you know that
let's go fight the demigod human
demi-human
queen
it is like a dance it's a good way to
put that glenn it's like a dance
um
i mean great i only have one great rune
we gotta get going on this playthrough
we're gonna take our time try and get
every boss in this play through
look around
smack some squirrels
you know how it do be
yes mitzi
oh that's a good idea i just don't want
to give that game any time of day at all
ugh
that game gives me the heebie-jeebies
man
that would that would have been pretty
funny though
another thing we should do on stream is
get into the pvp this is where i saw
that cave
over here right
yup
yup
i mean if there is one
hell yeah
earth bore cave
interesting
okay
big ass chat
oh okay dude
i can't see
oh my god
anything but mice man i can't see
there were way more of them in here than
i originally thought
let me get a torch going real quick
i have so many weapons holy crap okay
well now i want to get the chest man
hello
i
did you guys see my tweet today
where i was saying like the the toxicity
of comments just ramps up on the weekend
like crazy like all week i'll be getting
constructive nice
you know constructive feedback comments
you know whether they're like they like
what i make or not they're at least like
nice
and constructive
and then once like friday afternoon hits
like tick tock and youtube like the
toxic comments come out of [ __ ]
nowhere and they'll just be like this
content is so bad
imagine being this bad it's like
hello
where did where did you come from and i
swear it's all these kids who are like
done with school
for the week and they just get online
and they're just like
they're just mean
i don't understand i don't know why kids
are so angry all the time
i don't remember being this angry when i
was a teenager
uh but maybe i was i have no idea
i know i wasn't calling people's com or
okay more mice is where we use this
takes care of them pretty good
one attack so fast
okay no drop frame so far so i'm very
happy with how the stream is going
you didn't give a [ __ ] about a ton as a
teenager i really didn't but i wasn't a
dick
but i didn't care about anything when i
was a kid
like i was just mad chilling
oh god
okay
got it
all right chad i have a plan
we're gonna pop this
and i'm going to meteor this bear
it's a bad plan
it was a bad plan from the get-go
jesus
calm down bear
i give it frostbite yet
damn that hurts
got him
i'm just gonna hit it
nice
spell drake talisman
i think that negates magic damage
is not super important to us
what is a trina lily
a light purple water lily that is on the
verge of wilting material used for
crafting items exceedingly rare to find
a symbol of faith in saint trina
dulls the senses preventing
agitation
so it's
weed
nice
yo what's up justice uh i don't
understand the urge to say mean negative
things to people i don't either
um even if i think those things i never
say them out loud
ever
it's just like
why would i waste my time
saying that to somebody when i can just
like not interact with them at all if i
don't like what they do you
know personality trait of yours some
kids have fat man titties and need to
make others feel bad i agree with that
trey that's a great way to put that like
just fat man titties
and they're mad that they have fat man
titties so they go and
yeah
make others feel
about as good as they feel about
themselves
which isn't very
very much
oh god
wait these guys are easy look this guy's
gonna scream and i'm gonna kill him
scream dead
[Music]
oh my god
this weapon's really fun chat uh
oh
hello
now you're dead
oh it's used to sleep items
oh
i need to craft in this game don't i joe
that is one thing i have not done at all
is craft
i just grabbed this this stuff for no
reason apparently
hello dear
especially to say it to a stranger on
the internet weak move hiding behind a
computer screen talking [ __ ]
well that's the whole point it's like
none of these kids would say this stuff
if they were like in front of me
i don't think
no actually no shot
damn human queen
oops
oh actually
hold on chat i want to deflect
the shield i have deflects magic and
repels it back
which is kind of sick
this guy also accidentally kills his
people all the time damn it i go faster
gotta go fast
calm down
okay that hurt a lot actually
this is the most blood-borne boss i've
ever seen
at least in this there it is
what
that one's so hit
do it again
all right
yeah that worked
wait
no i went to a little boy
come on
come on
too slow
too slow i'm slow
there it is
boom
it does decent damage only one of that
hit
come on
and bang
why does it just go to like one random
dude
well
okay you know what
do the thing i want to see how much
damage we do
that is not a spell jake
i am so slow
is this a cool looking enemy though i
love it
okay let's see the damage
1836 holy crap
i need to upgrade this more
yeah i'm just going to kill it
dead
you get its staff and the crystal burst
which is kind of cool
big dick swaggin
is it a big magical
i don't know you tell me man
holy gosh nuggets
indeed
if they set it to your face
you'd hope you'd hop on your horse and
smite them down with that weapon
i just i just do this right here
like shut up kid
shut up kyle
i feel like kyle is such an unfortunate
name now
looks good for smiting
it is nikki
it is great for smiting
i got caught on a squirrel
okay what's over here
death
okay
so that's the first step
that way i just want to know what all
these ruins were
like what did this entire area look like
before the war
you know
okay we got little flower boys down here
big old nerd flowers ooh faith not
crystal tear
i don't think i've ever had that
so there's more over there
there
i think we can go
that way
i love your lore bids oh thank you
i'm glad you like them they're they're
fun to make because
most of the time it's just all like
uh speculation which is everything
in this game
i think a lot of people don't realize
that though where it's like yeah
my theory could be totally wrong but so
could yours
and then a lot of people are like no i
can't possibly be wrong so whatever you
say in this lore video it's different
from mine so you're wrong and you're
terrible
it's like oh okay
seems like people struggle to calm down
a little bit
when it comes to lore
there's a lot of people on those lore
videos will just be like no this is
completely wrong here's my theory
it's like okay
go make a video on it
like i did
go make your own i'd love to watch it
i watched 12 seconds heard three words i
understood well it's probably because
you watched about 12 seconds yeah
um og from software so i get that
laura's perspective and speculation well
there you go i think a lot of the new
[Music]
the new players
are like no it's this
no you're wrong it's like i just know
you're a child or a really weird person
uh when you're just like on a comment on
a lore video
it's like yeah
calm down buddy
sucks is i have to hit these guys twice
and one right there where'd this one go
where'd he go
he just did
whole part of the fun is hearing
everyone's perspective and opinion i
agree it's like if i'm wrong i don't
really care i'm just like
i don't know if i'm wrong nobody knows
if i'm wrong
um
and they don't know if they're right or
wrong either
some people just don't like that and
that's fine i just i'm telling you guys
right now i wish twitch had this before
i switched to youtube okay
there is a feature on youtube if you
didn't know
where i can hide a user
from my channel
they can still be subbed they can still
write comments
they just have no idea that nobody
including me can see what they say i
love that
because they could be like watch a video
and it's like hey man i told you in
another video that no no no no no no no
this isn't right
nobody will see it and they'll waste all
their time i freaking love that
it's just funny to me
you kept saying names and places i had
never heard of because you okay
think of this trey
you're likely not gonna watch a lore
video when you haven't played the game
you know what i mean
probably not
so
has twitch added that
really
i never knew it was there well actually
yeah but they couldn't type in chat and
they knew they were banned though
i like on youtube that the person has no
idea
they just waste their time
but you can like ban and hide yes
did you try the game tray or just the
video
don't think they can no they can't type
speculation makes awesome storytelling
totally agree
i had a oh there's a cave here
um
what was i gonna say
i had a comment
on one of my videos that was uh
i put it on i put it on discord actually
i believe it's meant to be god when i i
know um hold on let me take a look
because it's kind of a funny
it's funny it's from a while ago though
this guy said environmental storytelling
while fantastic is not a substitute for
actually telling a story the whole
discover the story on your own is a
[ __ ] cop-out
meaning he thinks from software
storytelling is a [ __ ] cop out to
not tell a story
which is um
hilarious to me
oops
like what a weird comment that guy
clearly has no [ __ ] idea what he's
talking about
i never read youtube comments honestly i
would not recommend it
it's awful
i have to
it is my job
but
some of them are just kind of dumb
just fine
haven't gotten the game yet i haven't
spent more than an hour straight playing
video games which isn't conductive to
this kind of game
oh it definitely can be like if you have
an hour a day to play this game you
should you'll finish it in
six months that's totally fine
you can play this game slow as hell
or as fast as you want
you know for me it's my job to play
video games so obviously i'm gonna
finish it a lot faster than other people
doesn't mean that's the only way to play
the game
okay
bang
this sword is massive
and i love it
yep
sometimes you get good comments though
i love constructive comments
a lot
like getting constructive feedback on a
video is so um
valuable
i'm just running through here oh god
oh god
oh let's see there's your issue trace
you're going to get obsessed
you're going to get obsessed
and then you won't be able to stop
the storytelling is my fave from
software miyazaki me too
it's um
the game doesn't hold your hand which i
i the last video i made was
all about why i love this game
that was one part of it is the game
doesn't hold your hand it doesn't tell
you everything word for word
you gotta go out figure it out
speculate
there could be multiple meanings
to something
which i love and some people hate
it's like all right whatever bro
whatever man
i don't know what boss is down here
let's go back to the door i skeletons
are such a waste of
time they don't give you nothing
all right whatever boss is in here
oh my god bro get off me
you never stop
jeez
oh absolutely i missed because i
finished my first play through lee in 58
hours
which is
super fast like i you know i went i beat
the game like i got the end credits
i missed
60 of the game i i only did forty
percent of the game and i beat the game
crazy
craziness
all right meteor time
what is in here
cemetery shade
okay
this thing is terrifying oh my god
ew
you're gross
okay and like really hard to hit okay
okay
how about we calm down just for a second
let's call let's think about this
okay this is bad
i reckon name i recommend new game plus
it depends on what you like doing
i like leveling one character personally
and then if you have the larval tears
you can always go respect and do a
different build if you want
you know
okay
[Music]
what is this thing man
i want to get a good look at it
hopefully i get something that we can
read
this thing is terrifying
okay
leave
ludo the headless
little
maybe i have been down here before i
just don't remember
no i haven't it's my first headless
legendary ash remains uses some in the
spirit of the headless little
spirit of the headless knight who leads
the mausoleum soldiers
wields a lance
enrobed in death and hurls spectral
lances at foes sacrifice his life so
that in death she could oh she could
continue to protect a soulless demigod
until their revival earning her the
hero's honor of urgery burial
interesting
these are the guys that protect the
walking
buildings the turtle buildings
with the bells underneath them
interesting
you guys ever look at this at the bottom
of dungeons as well
like that's weird
you know that's a little that's this is
odd
what am i looking at here i think it's
the it's the roots of the er tree
but it's also the um
the rune of death coming from underneath
it i think
yeah and infecting it
but why are people like
clamping to it
this guy's got a whole face going on
here bro
goddamn
it bleeds too
interesting
interesting first playthrough in 120
hours felt like uh
yeah i might at 60 to 75 percent now
doing a new game plus with a faith build
can't decide what build for the third
time this depends i did uh my first
playthrough was like a quality build it
was like across the board
uh everything was pretty good
uh
second playthrough was bleed
third playthrough was strength this
one's like an intelligent strength build
and then i am leveling a character to do
pvp because obviously this level is kind
of insane
i should go rest really quick
like 221 i think i guess i can level now
uh
i don't know
does it matter at this point
was bleed fun bleed was extremely fun i
enjoyed it
just depends on what you what you like
what does that get us to
153
that's not really worth
that brings it up a good amount
i don't think arcane helps us at all
it just doesn't matter i literally don't
need to level so i just won't
but i had fun with bleed i use the uh
rivers of blood
pretty much the entire play through and
it's it's really good
so these are the guys these are the guys
that we see from the er tree like when
you get
go up the the roots
near the door to the earth tree we see
those guys i wonder why they're out here
probably for the minor herd tree
actually
that would make sense
all right i'm laser beaming this guy
laser beam
[Music]
not very good
they
nerfed the [ __ ] out of that huh
okay i froze it
i don't think that's going to be very
good against this guy
should we meteor
why not
this is gonna hurt
oh
i should have got out my shield
mohammed thanks for the sub by the way i
appreciate you
ooh
i should mess around with my
what is it called
wondrous physic
flask
i should mess around with that
so wonder why these pot boys were here
and they're all dead
[Music]
the pop boys are the hardest like npcs
in this game to like
to understand because these pots
when they defeat their foes they grind
them up and put them inside of their pot
so that they can get bigger and stronger
we have one of those singing bats i
think
[Music]
i wonder
what she's singing
this is pretty
another npc we don't know that much
about are these bats
or at least the singing bats
no i haven't really done that one i i
found it and didn't know how to progress
it
which i do now
so we could do that
it's that chick right there singing trey
i can't even look down there
if i
i don't want to bother
[Music]
it's the song of lamb lamin lamentation
is that how you say that in latin
what does that mean
[Music]
[Music]
it is beautiful
for my first playthrough i just sat down
and listened for a while
i wonder what they're protecting
expression of grief
[Music]
why would she be singing that though
um
beautiful song lady
now you're dead
okay what were they protecting
a sliver of meat
basically a story how the lands fell
from grace
i mean that's the whole point of the
game right
or it's at least why
i mean the the elden ring shattered and
everything went to [ __ ] basically
right
fell from grace
was it doing that before
and now she's really creepy
that's weird that's down here to the
south this this area is
there's a lot to look at down here
because this area to me is the most
boring
is the is the south
but uh
i'm finding a lot more than i
would have thought i would have
very cool
we got the minor er tree
i mean i'll take a flask
oh come here
stop
thank you
wow
expression of grief
it's crazy how those bats go from like
singing such a beautiful song to
trying to kill you
we got pop boys all around this minor
archery
and these guys
look like just roots of it
torrent your head's gonna get right in
the way aren't you yep okay
that's fine
see a grace over there
oh that's where we came from okay
kind of on the upper part now could i
get across over there
i don't think so
a tartle
two things i refuse to hit in this game
are turtles and eagles
i just won't do it i won't touch them
you can't
can we make that jump
we can get down here i don't know if i
want to get down actually
okay
see you
platforming
okay
yes dog exactly
whoa whoa
oh oh
whoa
more than i thought more than i thought
yo
okay all them are dead
i'm gonna die
boom
me through let me get it off
i'm stressed
oh
jesus
all that for a rooney boy
does lightning strike on these flowers
nope
wait yeah they do they're like
glowing a bit
interesting
[Music]
well that area is scary
i wouldn't recommend that to anybody
it's pretty bad storm we got going on
here
okay can we get down there
weird that we can't is there
more this way
nope
how the hell do i get out of here
oh we gotta make some kind of jump here
huh
can we make that jump
might as well try
so you can't
now we know
now we know hopefully i don't lose all
those
we'll have to go back and get them
oh man
see i'm not even dying to any enemies
all right where were they
you should tell me
there you are
wait there's a tunnel
i didn't even see a tunnel
huh
i didn't see a tunnel down there or am i
tripping
man
well
i'm not even spending the room so i
don't care too much about them
but
i'd rather not lose them
too [ __ ]
uh-oh
oh they're just on the side there okay i
guess i could go down
and then uh
tp out
it's coming a little hot there
that's my bad
oh god we're dead
we're gonna die
traversing
oh boy okay
okay
one one step at a time here torrent
you have a tendency to just yourself out
of existence so
let's calm down
we're good
oh god not this again okay
is there a tunnel here
i could use please
[Music]
okay
nice
those bats in a group dude
they go nuts
okay it says there's a damn tunnel here
where
maybe it's all over here
i
see you
see i i look at that and i'm like yeah
we can survive that fall but we already
tested it and we can't
so
let's go over here
yeah it's below
we got it though
i just you know didn't want to die again
deal with all the bats that would have
been bad
so we want to go straight and take a
left
[Music]
you
got some farty boys over here
so there's a way to get back up that
area down there is kind of weird if you
maybe there was a better way to get down
but
i didn't see it
yep here it is
hmm
this is a tunnel we've been in
whoops
there's an area right there
gonna go straight and take a left
that would be uh
yeah
you go straight and then you take a left
nascar 101.
what are these guys doing down here
okay
interesting
is that one sleeping
on the job
nerd
oh it's a whole mine
oh yeah
okay
let's explode
oh chill sir
things are gross
these guys like people who tried to
become dragons and it just went terribly
wrong
big smack
not fully sure on that one
these are all smithing ones
pretty good farm early game but
i never found it before
[Music]
okay
hello
oh we just got some bad boys down here
these guys don't seem to be doing
nothing
all these guys work
okay
where did you come from
okay sir hold on
sir
i'm down from there
thank you
sir
sir i'm gonna need you to chill i'm
gonna use your relax
got a leafy boy
this guy not bother me
i actually have never tested that like
if i don't take his rock will he just
chill
oh boss fight
boss fight
i think
usually
dude i've seen you open
doors way way bigger than this one
scaly misbegotten
i'm gonna freeze you
well that was a joke
jesus oh this way they get that anchor
got it
okay let's explore more
what a boss
sure that one's a lot harder when you're
not level 200 and something
got some somber ones down here this is a
pretty good mine where are we
it would make sense for it to be one
since the south is pretty much one of
the easier areas
i think tomorrow we'll go and look at uh
caled
in depth
it's a good starting area to look at
though
so they don't bother you unless you take
their show and make sense
make you know they're working hard on it
and then uh i just come in and snag it
it's probably really annoying
okay uh i already went through here
let's let's go back
dude i have to remember to like sit up
straight
i'm really bad at slouching when i get
into a game
hello
soft cotton
anything over here
what a lonely person
and and they're dead so it doesn't
really matter if they're lonely or not
somber one
very nice
game is lagging to get them out in here
i guess this would make sense that it's
the the mourn
mine
because we're near mooren castle
does it go up anywhere
there's a lot to mine down here
all right cool
let's see what tick tock's doing today
oh god
volume all the way up when you open tick
tock is not
not good
oh it's doing pretty good nice
someone said when are you supposed to
explore the red area because i'm in the
snow place right now
tell me this guy hasn't gone to caled
but he's gone to the the mountaintops of
the giants
what a noob
that is a wicked oversight not to check
out caitlyn
okay
let's go isn't there a scaly boy at the
end of this right here i think so
yeah
not a scaly boy
demi human
[Music]
i love the music in this game
i really do
it reminds me of the music i'd feel when
i was playing like skyrim for the first
time
like
over 10 years ago now that is so weird
to say
gosh
i guess we can go do the turtle thing up
here
you gotta to open this uh
castle
tower over here
so we go to the front of this
uh excuse me seek three wise beasts and
a turtle disappears before you
see those i can kill
because they're not real
they're summons
die
no chill bro
i'm trying to kill you but
relax my god
this is a beefy wolf
there we go
okay so there's one turtle
one turtle boy
i think one's in a bush like right here
there it is
right in this
bush then another one is invisible in
this little pond like right in the
middle
boom
seal open and i think we get another
memory
slot if we use that one for uh
spells and stuff
just sick
still hear
wolves a lot of wolfy boys around here
i think i already have the maximum yeah
i already have the maximum memory slots
but uh a new um
a new memory slot would be there
we got the max we're pretty cool
i don't know why i'm using torrent right
here but
[Music]
i guess we go to the castle that is like
the weakest looking castle
it it doesn't go any
like it doesn't spread out anywhere it's
just boom
that is an erect
castle
i did hear that you should just kill
merchants oh we could kill uh hold on
because you get the bell if you killed a
merchant so you don't have to go looking
for the merchant if you need a specific
thing for them you can just buy them all
in one place
but i don't want to kill the merchants
because they're
they're nice
uh we can pass time till nightfall and
i'm pretty sure
a night's calvary comes out at night
like right at the entrance here
yep there it is
come here
i'm gonna
laser beam you
now
get some distance get some distance
laser beam
[Music]
laser beam is really bad now isn't it
god it's so bad
when you can apply like a
frostbite with this
everything else worthless
let's do one of these boys
not very good i didn't really hit him
with it though
sir i need this thank you
this guy's spazzing out the heck's going
on
i look down at my flash for half a
second he jumps me oh no
this is bad
sir
stop doing that
now
oh i'm dead
never mind
stop it
okay
nice
oh you get his flail for that nice
i like it
and barricade shield barricade shield is
quite good too
i like to move it move it
i have i looked up here before i don't
think so
i don't think i've gone over here
you know before i continue
straight to the castle
go this way
look at that there's a little little
house out here man
hello
a yellow ember whoa
we got crazy rats
what
the flame of frenzy eyes
yeah those are crazy eyes what's going
on here
yup
interesting
another minor tree
um that's the one i i went to that's
right i'm on the other side now got it
okay those bats are mad chillin
what is going on in this house
hello
open
i don't have any commands on here yet
trey
i don't think that one will be a thing
oh what is that
yellow ember
there you go
there you go oh i can go this way
uh it's probably just
yeah kinda
another way to get down there if you
want to go around the
giant i suppose
i'm your biggest fan
i mean that's what the watch time says
you're not wrong
let me go pee and grab a water really
quick
[Music]
i should add a water ready to go
i apologize
yeah i'm gonna do that real quick get
him go pee grab water
and uh i'll be right back boys
give me like two minutes
two minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hold up
[Music]
okay tell me
what you guys think of this because i
saw a tick tock this morning of this
i saw a tick tock where this guy
and a bunch of other people in the
comments agreed with him too
that
you're like not supposed to wash your
hair
like with uh
with shampoo
like chemicals and [ __ ]
this guy swore by that if you just like
don't wash your hair just wet it down
in a shower like normal shower just
don't wash it with any chemical shampoos
and
after it'll be greasy for like two weeks
and then after that
your hair will like release essential
oils
naturally and your hair will be like
more healthy i was like what
it's crazy
that's a garbage opinion i don't know
i've always just washed my hair with
shampoo
picking garbage pinning
he had like
10 million views and
all the comments are like yes
agree
it's like i've never heard that in my
life
then again i've never questioned it so i
have no idea
okay let's go beat up this guy
he was preaching that uh like shampoo
chemicals can like mess up your hair
or like kill the hair make it not as
healthy
so trying to shoot an arrow at me my guy
there we go
the bigger they are
they suck
you had released fewer oils but never
zero
you need something like chamfew which
acts like a mild detergent so to bond
with the both the oils and the water to
be rinsed off
i have no idea
i might give it a shot
actually like my hair is really healthy
my hair has always been really healthy
so
i'm probably not gonna mess with it
yeah over i i have heard that from like
uh
like metal told me that too it's you can
over wash your hair katie told me that
as well you can definitely overwash like
definitely should wash your hair with
shampoo just not every single time you
shower like every day
calm down bats i'm trying to read
the siege of castlemorn a lone hero
fights for his vengeance only to follow
the hand of lord godfrey
is the lone hero
um
like irena's dad
is that what they're talking about and
he loses to godfrey
or is it somebody else
because i'm i'm pretty sure i forget the
guy's name at the top is it alexander
not alexander
something
the captain up there
works for godz rick
let's go find out
i swear my ass off every day i need to
watch everything daily or i smell like a
homeless man
yeah that's that's also true it probably
depends on your
your workload each day
as well
very very true
i should see what quest lines we have
going on
because i think i need to go back
i'm gonna go back to the round table
cause i think i have a quest line to do
i need to give like this bottle to
nafeli if she's here
is that door always closed
she's not here
why is that door closed now
she don't care
um
maybe i haven't done in this playthrough
and i'm tripping it might have been a
different one oh this is a rare occasion
i can't remember the last time a new
tarnish made their way to the round
table
very well
as your senior
i beat you welcome
it is safe here
you may let down your guard
okay
oh trey i didn't tell you that i started
uh 75 hard
if you even know what that is greetings
nice to see you again
my name is rodrika yeah i'm i'm like new
to this area i i must have been doing it
in a different playthrough
of the two fingers and gathering place
of champions who vie to become elder and
lord
i never knew the guidance bestowed upon
us tarnished had such fantastic roots
although
it's all a bit much for me in truth
i'm still looking for my own purpose
you don't know what it is so 75 hard is
a 75 day challenge
where
uh there's certain rules that you have
to follow
which is
very strict diet you can pick your diet
but you have to stick to it 75 days
straight
no alcohol 75 day all of this is 75 days
in a row and if you mess up you have to
restart everything but it's strict diet
no alcohol two workouts a day
an hour each one of those workouts has
to be outdoors
you drink a gallon of water a day
read 10 pages of self self help book
um
is there more to it
i can't remember
think that's everything
yeah but you have to do that all of that
75 days in a row it's like to teach
discipline
it seems
difficult
still looking for my own purpose
it's another area that i have not looked
at very much yet
trey you want to see something weird
those are just fingers
hairy fingers
sounds less than lovely i already do
some of that but i wouldn't want to do
that
yeah well
it's more about the discipline and it's
it's like supposed to suck you know
it's like not supposed to be fun
i work with cameron hoog
who acts as my diet coach in training
programmer nice
it seems like a fun challenge that i'd
want to do for 75 days but not much more
than that you know
look there
the fingers shudder with exuberance
fine work brave tarnished
the greater will is please so the
greater will in this game
is
god essentially in this game in this
world
and these fingers
all the two fingers speak for the
greater will
and then these finger readers these
women
can
translate what the fingers are saying
now
go forth i think i already have the
things she gave me
i figured that was the cameron you were
talking about
he did go to our high school i was i was
wondering that
he does natural bodybuilding shows i can
go really hard for even a month
uh but i wasn't consistent with my food
which meant that my weight was always
going up dude everything about like
weight loss weight gain depending on
what you're trying to do
is
90 diet
80 maybe 75 but like
everything is diet dude everything it's
crazy you can work your [ __ ] ass off
in the gym it doesn't mean [ __ ] if you
if you go and eat bad
this all gets negated
at least for my body that's what happens
that could not be the case for everybody
but for me
bro i eat a cheat like one cheeseburger
and like a month of work is gone it's
like all gone completely
about queen marca america
is it um like america or is it marica
i can never
say it properly enough
queen
a
america
in truth
but after the elton rings shattering
she was imprisoned in the earth tree
a grim punishment for shattering the
order so she shattered the ring and was
imprisoned inside the tree
i didn't know she was in prison inside
the tree
true
she remains a god and a visions vessel
confer great runes
to become elden lord and join queen
america as her consort
the fingers
have willed it so
okay
wicked all right
um
yo i can have that guy's armor
the briar grieves
nice dude i'm down 27 pounds since
november feeling good 222 this morning
with some nice
street
street street i can't say that word
coming in nice man good for you dude
sweet sweet
good for you
um bro
in 2019
i was 220
that was bad
i was
fat now i'm uh i think last time i
weighed myself i was like 185
which i think is healthy for me
i've always had like
a bigger body
but you know of course my [ __ ] doctor
will be like so for your height you're
supposed to weigh like 150 and i'm like
that seems a little far
seems a bit of a stretch but 220 was
definitely like
way too much
i think down like 40 since then
it feels great
okay what else can i get out of here
so i might wear
that armor
i can get her spear
oh i can use the remembrance
yeah
i'm gonna go to one of those turtle
dudes the shells to get the other part
because i can use her thing
is this hers
yes
does it look cool
yo it matches too
nice
very cool
am i even swinging here no
bmi scale worst thing ever
yeah yeah yeah true it it so depends on
your body type for that [ __ ]
100
well i took you for no matter today
our boy huge bro
but she has a gift
for spiritual
i saw another one like how long ago
their eyes share the same hue
i wonder who
as eve noticed the chains
nothing special
i'm a prisoner and these are my chains
i'm trapped by the hole but then he goes
on to say that he's not a prisoner
so like you're we ask him you're a
prisoner
no
much into it well no grudge against you
my being a prisoner is no fault of yours
besides
my own mind smithing despite my
differences the weapons get stronger all
the same
even time
technique never fails i love huge huge
is awesome
he's talking about queen america
the sheer terror of her
fax man
well these are all sombers how much does
this go up
27 is this even worth it
to upgrade sorcery scaling goes way up
and the and the ant
i should do this
we need a five banger
where can we get a five banger
because we get one through four from eg
and i bought all of them
i wonder if i can buy one over here
actually
i can see my abs a little bit but i'm
the border between overweight and obese
yeah
i think it all like for me dude like
if i feel good
that's what matters
that's what i want is to feel good i
don't really care too much about
you know
what the
doctor says i guess or or something but
or what the bmi scale will tell me to
weigh because the bmi scale literally
tells me since i'm short too li
that i'm supposed to weigh like 150. i'm
like dude i haven't weighed 150 since
like eighth grade
like and i wasn't i wasn't fat
um
the only time i was fat was like uh in
2019 when i was just eating like i
didn't give a [ __ ]
in 2019 and then kova didn't help either
that kind of scaled off a bit to like
maybe 210
and then
we've been going pretty pretty healthy
for the last like year and we're down
like 40 pounds
which is nice
but i'm short too
so but i i always i've always had like
big tree trunk legs like my whole family
has them
um
so it there's just like more there
there's more muscle on my legs muscle
weighs more than fat
i'm always just gonna weigh more than
than the scrawny or kid who's the same
height as me you know i mean
so
that's how that's how it'd be
how's everything going
fantastic glenn how's your day going
we'll say i'm i'm enjoying the youtube
stream this is uh not too different from
from twitch i thought it was going to be
a lot
more different it's
it's not
i enjoy it
sofia still in here
i didn't notice that she has blonde hair
underneath her
little
mask there her little hood
i'll ask trey trey should we get a hug
from her greetings great champion called
by grace
i
am circumstances yup i got wide
shoulders too bro big tree trunk legs
would you allow me to hold you
yep blood pressure cholesterol resting
heart rate
yeah i don't think overall weight is
really that important anymore
but for me bro
uh
for me to lose that much weight wasn't
really working out that much it was all
diet
all of it was diet i think for the last
year trey i've been eating less than
1500 calories a day like i just really
don't eat that much food
and i got used to that over time
hugs are good
so her name is fia the deathbed
companion and she wants to give us a hug
i'm legit built like a tank here you're
[ __ ] linebacker man you're you're
running back you know big boy
which doesn't mean you're out of shape
doesn't mean you're fat you're just
not this
you're not a scrawny little [ __ ]
okay
there's some guys who are like six
inches taller than me and they weigh
like 50 pounds less and they just
you know
in shape quote-unquote you're just
skinny as hell
you got no meat on you
i'll let her hold me
my thanks
great champion she gives good hugs too
that's the other thing that she gives a
good ass hug
she squeezes
oh
very warm
oh stan
are you the pro youtube streamer i've
seen all over tick-tock
i guess so man
what's up dude i am afraid come back to
me
should you require another
i will take you in my arms i need to
snip my nose hairs
any any of any of you guys get like
really bad nose hairs
i have wicked it's bad
her questline's [ __ ] awesome
she's the only quest line that i've uh
explained on use or i did a a guide on
youtube before
the rest of them i feel like are pretty
easy uh like ronnie's questline i feel
like everyone just like
automatically does her quest line
i guess there's some others i could do
but i haven't
been able to choose which ones i am
pleased to see only old people have that
would you like me to hold you
once more
the blessing is still a flame in your
breast dear
would you like to be held
regardless
no
no thank you
thank you for the hug mommy
i trimmed them occasionally mine get
really bad
i feel like the older i get the hairier
i get is weird
like it's like the puberty part
of hair
held off till i was 25.
it's kind of weird
it's like now i gotta start shaving like
some other parts like a lot more than i
used to
down below and up front you know
and behind i mean [ __ ]
it's tmi oh i see you've just arrived
bro i've been here dawg
this guy right here no idea what's going
on
the
i might cancel them
ensuring order regains its proper form
writing rule over men
by the way
do you still see it
the guidance of grace
i do
i don't believe you
would you like me to zoom the camera up
my nose you are something of a rare
breed
well
what do you say
care to learn an incantation see i have
no hair on my back
but it's all like
you know
dude it it it's my balls and my [ __ ]
i have a prayer book that
is a work of heresy oh sorry invitations
bear no lineage from the tree
very well
yes i did
no i want that
man did you just eat that from me
that didn't sound very pronounced this
time around
i've done all this i haven't been to
ranny
what am i doing on this
who's this
oh yeah
let's see what ronnie's doing
harry jake listen
listen man
i'm
okay
tmi
moving on
and this one's chair
imagine being that chair getting knocked
over
nerd
okay
kill him i actually cannot attack
anybody
inside of the round table which is where
i was just at
i can't even attack
is this rena's rise
yes
rena is the teacher of ronnie
and we have selvius down at the bottom i
believe
okay let's start randy's dealio we
should also like look around here as
well
this
i hate that delay
bruh
that was kinda badass
my bad
[Music]
whoa
have you seen that before that was sick
that was awesome
what is this
oh
he just sprayed some [ __ ] in front of
him oops
ow
oh yeah he disappears
half healthy goes away
nerd
that was awesome though i've never seen
that dragon do that uh
that's
sword spell attack that was sick
yeah this is ronnie's place
like do these wolves not attack you if i
just like chill
yeah that's i was wrong about that
theory
[Music]
just want to say thanks for all the
elden ring and 400 videos you're doing
awesome content my dude thank you man
thank you brendan i appreciate that dude
i'm i'm glad you enjoy it
i'm having a lot of fun doing it
so thank you for watching
i don't know why i hit that table
the heck
what was that
i thought that was a bird on the end
like a little yellow bird
but thank you for the kind words three
very nice
dab
hey listen i'm gonna get monetized again
on youtube here pretty soon
i'll get i'll get the membership buttons
we'll we'll have some we'll have some
custom emotes stan okay
again and badges
i might have you guys decide what kind
of badge you want if you want to be a
member
we could just do the crown again that
seemed to be fine
and then i will look at that uh that
plug-in ludwig made to see if like it
can translate from twitch over to here
because that was a really cool plug-in
but i wasn't sure if that was just for
him
ronnie
this this chick
i will say
is [ __ ] awesome
like this is one of the best characters
in video games i've ever experienced
she is a bad ass
no reason in particular though claims
i stole death long ago
and search now for the dark path
i know stan one day append the whole of
it
and rid the world of all that came
before
well
has that roused thy interest
absolutely i see
a choice well made
thou heard a rare sword
not many would have accepted the offer
but i require as much of those under my
command
i anticipate good work from me
good call thank you for hiring me good
then i ask we proceed with haste let's
get it
in my service
a half-woven warrior
by the name of blythe
blythe is live
in searching for the hidden treasure of
knock
knock
i have called for blithe to greet thee
below
take from him the particulars
ah
and they will thou find eg
my war counsellor
and salivas preceptor in the sorceress
arts also
heed not their peculiarities
feel secure
so they're weird
i'm sure the others will be doing just
the same
see i feel like ronnie would be great on
a show like big brother where she uses
her friends for their advantages that
they can give her and she can just toss
them to the side if they if they [ __ ]
with her at all
badass
thou needs not indulge them unduly
but they too wish to appraise thy worth
has been a passing long time since a
newcomer entered my service after all
okay
i will go meet with them
but yeah we can uh
i'll talk and discord stan about what
potentially emotes we would want here on
youtube
because my channel is currently um
they're reviewing
um not that i'm in trouble or anything
i'm not in trouble but it's uh
they're reviewing my monetization
options
so i can get like a membership badge and
it's or a member yeah membership option
and stuff
lady ronnie has explained everything
again
i'm told that you are searching for
nokron with blithe
i will give you whatever guidance i can
and pray for your success
thank you man
let us give all that we can of ourselves
together
for lady ronnie
hmm
you guys notice the so eg is like one of
those giants we see pulling the um
giant
uh crates or apparently they're coffins
and they have like holes in their chest
right but eg has
something in there
that that like i'm really curious of
there is a
like a a tombstone
wrapped up inside of his belly or chest
area or whatever
it's kind of cool
and we got blight down here
i heard about you
good to finally meet
name's blythe
sworn sword to mistress ronnie
glad to have you aboard
well
getting right to business okay stan i'm
situated in limgrave right now
the eternal city of nokron lies
somewhere at the bottom of this land
this is pretty cool i'm very curious of
what it is
see if i can't find the road to knock
wrong from there
don't keep me waiting i
this guy's a dick i really don't want to
work with this guy at all
but i should for his questline
this is the type of guy that would like
study art history
[Laughter]
i ask that you kindly try not to drag us
all down with you
okay i reside in another tower close by
come and pay me a visit
should you wish to be of actual service
to mistress rani
if it were up to me i wouldn't waste my
time on the likes of you
but who am i to stand against the wishes
of my lady
oh
how to be a douchebag 101
that guy right there gemini
i think i called the elevator up by
accident sure did
i'm so stupid
what if i just drop down on him right
now i mean he's a ghost he's not
actually there
or he's a summon
do my fit
like the way i look in this game right
now
are you you guys tell me what do you
prefer here because i'm always messing
around with the helmet
you prefer this
or
where is it this
this looks kind of clean too
a little hair in the back
i might rock this for a minute see how i
feel cool
all right i met with your boys
oh i shall soon enter my slumber
and it will be some time before i wake
this doll's body is not without its
hindrances
still ah
so it's the doll that has to go to sleep
i look forward to the good news when i
arise
very cool
and it will be some time i have
i look forward
very interesting so now with her
um let's go to selves tower
for sure
let's go to his tower
that was a sneeze by the way
and uh we'll go from there
then we can meet blight
in the city or in the
at the well in the miss woods so that we
can go to the nocron city
his towers down here
must be very important if you have a
tower
like if you're cool enough to have one
so this is another area we should
explore a lot more because like what is
going on around here
it's all just a bunch of ruins
a bunch of ruins
i'm assuming from the war
hello
did you not realize i was merely being
polite
you
provincials never cease to amaze
yeah
i think you're here now
perhaps i'll give you something to do
i'd like you to find a woman called
nafeli to administer a potion
even you can do that much can't you
maybe
okay good good
now i shall hand over the potion i'll
trust anything this guy says
not a thing
find nefari and ensure she drinks it i
expect clad tidings
and soon
okay
i have no time for idol chitchat
the only thing i will hear from you is a
report of your tasks completion
are we understood
then our future
then off you trot
yeah this guy this guy
no no trust
at all
with him
but i'm pretty sure
she's under here
if she's not then she's at the round
table hold
so
let's run over there
if she's not
right under
where this way
i'm not sure if i have to go the round
table hold first or go here first
so we're about to about to find out
big 99
[Music]
ding-a-ling
yeah this swipe
these guys were at the at the shaded
castle
i wonder what they're doing
either out there or they're from here
god
there's so many questions
kind of rocking this helmet over the
other one
oh we got these badasses huh
see
yeah somewhere under here
what is this ash of war
vow of the
in
man words i can't pronounce very well
something i won't use is what that is
okay she should be under this bridge
it doesn't look like she is
so let's go to the round table
uh-oh someone's trying to kill us
where
stop it
stop it
son
should be right out of uh
gideon's
room
gideon's right there
she over here
mitchell
oh he's not even in there
she's not there
i've never seen this room open without
gideon in here that's
actually kind of weird
interesting
okay
nephili is usually standing right here
oh we got the dung eater
am i fat rolling
wait for real
i did notice i was running a little bit
more weird
if i get rid of the torch
there it is have you ever felt the curse
with your whole being
the box upon life itself
feared
and despised by all
reviled blessing
apparently not
you all but a lamb
as strange as any farm and
ignorance of your own ignorance
you no longer interest me
i've been long without peace
don't spoil my quiet dude
damn i asked you not to disturb me
be thankful of the whole serenity
it is all that keeps your death and
defilement at bay
so basically what this guy does is he
[ __ ] corpses
he kills people and then defiles them
so pretty good guy
he he's the dung eater
that's his name
the cursed dung eater
he's just
evil gross
disgusting incarnate
um have i triggered you yet thank
goodness i'm still looking for myself
i need to tell you what huge said
because you're good at spirit tuning
you're telling me i possess
some kind of gift
i don't believe you
but
if i do have this talent and goodness
knows it would be my first
i suppose i should try to hone it
shouldn't i absolutely you should master
hugh to teach me
certainly he does appear intimidating
and holds no love for us tarnished
but i know he's trapped here at the
round table hold
so
i can tell
he's a gentle soul underneath it all
huge
do be the man let me try out this other
armor set
that i got
the uh briar armor
battered iron armor from a foreign land
which we know is eochad i think is what
it's called
worn by elmer of the briar the wind the
winding rusted iron briars are the mark
of the
of the guilty
and typically indicate a sentence of
death
elmer
murdered numerous instructors and
merchants and was known as the
bell-bearing hunter
that's kind of cool
interesting
very interesting okay
helmet
battered iron helmet from foreign land
the winery cursor uh says same thing
oh my god
okay
do i have this whole set like everything
briar gauntlets do they say anything
else
no they all say the same thing
at least it looks like anyway
all right how do we feel about this
armor set
i'm
leaning toward a no i think i looked
more be badass before let's go back
up now we're naked
whoops
that's a no from me
kind of cool though
see you
should i do radons
gauntlets and and leggings
because they they look like
yeah
i look like a frost
guy now
like uh like the the fluffiness of
radon's gauntlets is like trying to stay
warm like i'm from a cold area
it's kind of cool
okay
so i don't know where nafeli is i don't
i actually don't know what triggers her
um have i not beaten godric i i know i
have
yeah i beat godric because she's
supposed to help you with godric as well
i did that a little bit early i believe
so
i don't know where she is i don't know
what tell me who is this bigger reader
i have to meet them for some i'm pretty
sure
eg
ronnie
selvius
we met the servant
okay
fine tower limb grave we've already gone
there
okay what i'm gonna do is
i'm lost on what to do
so i think i'm gonna call the stream for
today i will be back tomorrow
at noon
central standard time
noon cst is my plan to stream here on
youtube um wednesday through sunday it's
all stream tomorrow and sunday and then
i'm going to take a couple days off and
then we'll just do
wednesday through sunday at noon here on
youtube that's my plan
streams will be about three hours long
each time
just kind of just kind of do them get
them out there i think it's fun
i like it i like streaming here on
youtube it feels good it felt better
than i thought it was going to today
so
just nice short
concise cool streams
we'll be back at it tomorrow guys
appreciate the support thank you for
coming over from twitch if you did or or
coming and watching on youtube i
appreciate it i really do
so thank you all for watching
and i will see you tomorrow at 12 cst
have a great day see you soon